Madame web is a truly dynamic character
hi it's Cassie web when you first meet
Cassie she is a paramedic in New York
City and doesn't really let people in
you have a winning personality I guess I
got yours by
mistake and then things take quite a
turn when Cassie begins to experience
her
Clairvoyance she thinks she's losing her
mind this is an emergency get off the
train in this one moment Cassie connects
all three of their lives that man is
trying to kill you Madame web's powers
are really interesting she's able to see
into the future and because she's able
to see
it she's able to prevent it let's try
that
ID it's really interesting all it plays
on fate or destiny you don't think this
is weird how we're all
connected it's honestly like the least
weird thing that's happened all
day